مازن ابدا معك متى من المقرر ان يتم
تشييع جثمان الشهيد صالح العاروري وكيف
تبدو التداعيات حتى الساعه في
لبنان في الواقع سلمى بالنسبه لجنازه
التشييع ستتم يوم غد من المفترض ان تصدر
تفاصيل اضافيه حول التوقيت والمراسم وكيف
ستقام ولكن حتى الان المعطيات الاوليه
تشير الى انها يوم غد في ب
ظهرا على مستوى التداعيات يمكن القول ان
لبنان اليوم امام تحد كبير وان حزب الله
امام اختبار صعب وامتحان كبير ايضا في
كيفيه التعامل والتعاطي مع عمليه الاغتيال
التي حصلت برمزيات متعدده لا سما ان هذا
الاستهداف يحصل في قلب ضاحيه بيروت
الجنوبيه وبالتالي في رساله متعدده
الوجهات بالنسبه لحزب الذي كان قد رسم
خطوطا حمراء سابقا قبل معركه طوفان الاقصى
وقبل السابع من اكتوبر كان كلامه واضحا
على لسان امينه العام ويتعلق بان اي
استهداف لاي مسؤول في المقاومه من قبل
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي س سيلاقي عقابا
وردا واضحا ولكن مع تغير المعادلات بعد
السابع من اكتوبر ومع انطلاق المواجهات
هنا في لبنان في اليوم التالي لتلك
العمليه يمكن الحديث عن ان متغيرات عديده
حصلت وق قواعد الاشتباك باتت متغيره يوميا
نستفيق على تغير في كيفيه التعامل مع هذه
التطورات على مستوى الجبهه الجنوبيه لذلك
السؤال اليوم الذي يطرح في بيروت هو على
مستويين المستوى الاول رسميا كيف تتعامل
السلطات اللبنانيه من خلال الموقف الذي
وضعته وايضا المستوى الثاني يتعلق بحزب
الله سواء من خلال الكلمه المرتقبه للامين
العام اليوم عند الساعه السادسه بتوقيت
المحلي او من خلال اي ارتدادات على مستوى
الجبهه الجنوبيه او اي عمل امني او عسكري
قد يقوم به حزب الله على المستوى الرسمي
سلمى هنالك تعاطي بات واضحا من خلال رئيس
حكومه تصيف الاعمال الذي سرع الى تحميل
اسرائيل المسؤوليه واعتبر بان اسرائيل
ونتنياهو يحاول ان يصدر ازمته ازمه قطاع
غزه وما وصلت اليه الحال هناك يحاول ان
يصدر هذه الازمه وفق توصيف مقاطي الى
لبنان
مستدرج لبنان بحزب الله وب اللبنان الرسمي
الى مربع جديد يفتح الجبهات على طولها
وعرضها هنا في الجنوب وفق توصيف مقاطي ومن
هنا هو تحدث عن ضروره الضغط الدولي على
على على اسرائيل كي تلتزم بالقرارات
الدوليه هذا الشان ولكن الشان الاخر
ويرتبط بكيفيه مقاربه حزب الله لما حصل
على مستوى عمليه الاغتيال كما بات معروفا
فان البيان الذي صدر عن الحزب بالامس تحدث
عن عقاب على هذه الجريمه التي وصفها بانها
اعتداء على السياده اللبنانيه واعتبر
بانها تشكل خطرا كبيرا ضمن المواجهه التي
تخاط بين اسرائيل وبين كامل محور المقاومه
وفق توصيفه وبالتالي هو فتح الامكانيات
على موضوع المواجهه وكيفيه تدحرج الامور
بعد هذه العمليه التي نفذتها اسرائيل
والتي اقتلت من خلالها العاروري ورفاقه
وبالتالي الان هنا الحديث من قبل مقربين
من حزب الله عن انه عاده حزب الله اولا
سينتظر بطبيعه الحال ما سيصدر خلال الكلمه
المرتقبه التامين العام ولكن من المعروف
عن انه لا لا يتصرف وفق مبدا رده الفعل
بمعنى انه سيقوم برد ما ولكن هذا الرد
مكانه زمانه كيفيه تنفيذه على المستوى
العسكري او على المستوى الامني هنالك
اسئله مفتوحه على عده مستويات ولكن بطبيعه
الحال يمكن الحديث عن ان واقع الجبهه
الجنوبيه هنا حيث اقف كان متغيرا قبل حصول
عمليه الاغتيال ك كنا نرصد تغيرا فعليا
على مستوى و حجم الضربات التي توجهها
اسرائيل وايضا في المقابل حجم العمليات
العسكريه التي كان ينفذها حزب الله والتي
اخذت منحا متصاعدا خلال المرحله الماضيه
على كافه المستويات لاسما من الناحيه
الكميه والنوعيه وهو ما ادى الى ارتفاع في
عدد الاصابات في قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ولكن اما وقد حصل هذا الاستهداف بهذه
الطريقه وبهذه الرمزيه فان كل الانظار
اليوم تنشد الى كيفيه تعامل حزب الله مع
هذا المتغير هل س نشهد ارتفاعا في
العمليات على مستوى جنوب لبنان كيف سيكون
هذا الرد هل هو محصور هنا ام ان ما ورد في
بيان حزب الله على مستوى ان المواجهه باتت
تاخذ منحنى خطيرا مع كامل محور المقاومه
قد يكون في طياته يحمل تاويلات وتفسيرات
بان ما تترقبه وما يترقبه كثيرون على
مستوى الرد قد لا يكون محصورا على مستوى
الجبهه الجنوبيه ولكن هنالك جبهات متعدده
من غزه الى الضفه الغربيه مرورا بلبنان
وغيرها من من الساحات التي باتت مفتوحه
ضمن هذه المواجهه الكبيره والتي اعقبت
العدوان الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه لذلك
يمكن الحديث عن مجموعه من المعطيات ولكن
ابرزها حاله الترقب الفعليه وهنالك سعي
حثيث على المستوى الرسمي اللبناني لايصال
رسائل الى كل من يعنيهم الامر على المستوى
الغربي والمستوى الدولي بان من كان يطالب
لبنان بتطبيق القرار 171 وسحب حزب الله
الى ما وراء جنوب الليطاني الى عفوا الى
ما وراء شمال الليطاني بعجاله ان هنالك
الان من يتحدث ومن يقول في لبنان بان
اسرائيل هي من تخرق القرار 1701 وبالتالي
هي من تخرق السياده واخر دليل على ذلك
عمليه الاغتيال التي طالت العاروري في قلب
الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت